we were talking 10 minutes ago about
that post that ended up in the community
about
finding you know finding those pictures
on your social feed that's what we're
going to get into yeah
okay yeah so let's talk about that so
this this will come up with just about
every guy you're dating and then you
realize that
there's a guy in her social feed whether
it's on facebook or instagram that she's
got pictures with from her past
who may have been somebody that alpha
widowed her
for example um you're obviously not
going to approach it from a jealous
rage like delete that stuff right now
because i said so because i'm the man
how should guys handle stuff like that
paul like what's your view on that yeah
so this is good this is really good one
because
what guys if she's in is this even true
like if you're
are her apex alpha which you won't you
always
want to be that you think you're that
but you know it's hard to know
especially in the beginning
like right off but um
when you approach it if she's in your
frame
and you give too much credibility to
men in her sexual past that will cause
her
because she's going to follow your lead
to wonder and think
if these men are actually better than
you if you come across as
threatened by men in her past then she's
gonna
have to she causes her which she wasn't
thinking about it at all because she's
having these awesome sexual experiences
with you
and hypergamy causes her to lean towards
you as her best and she's not even
thinking about
five years ago guy that she banged that
summer or whatever but
when you make an issue out of it and it
comes across like you're threatened
now it causes her to have to think about
her sexual experiences with that guy
and then she has to wonder and start
asking herself these questions
well is this guy better than the guy i'm
with because he seems threatened by it
you know
and so it actually pushes them into
thinking other men are better you don't
want to do that at the same time though
you need to compliance test it because
if she's pining for a guy in her past
she'll do it and she'll never tell you
about it
and you'll find out later i mean women
are so deceptive about these things
and so you'll find out after you're
completely invested and living together
and you have two children or whatever
right you don't want that
and so a lot of times what happens is
women when they're not
in a new relationship that's exceeded
some of these things or that any blew
any these things out of the water
or when they get into these like little
relationships those guys don't really
have
frame so she leaves the old photos up in
the old couple's photos
with her and some other guy from five
years ago she never cleans
her photos out she just leaves that
stuff there let's
linger now you'll notice though she
doesn't have
photos of ugly guys or guys that she
didn't that that that isn't a point of
validation for her
you'll notice in her social media i mean
go through it you know look at these
girls
do they have all that that ugly guy that
i
slept with for a couple weeks and had a
few pictures taken with him was
you know that's embarrassed about do i
have that guy i'm embarrassed about
on my social media feed no they don't
but they have the guys that they look at
as a point of validation
their sexual experiences and men of
their past become
points of validation for them because
women unfortunately use dick for
validation just the way it is
and so so when she meets you though
and she's in the dating phase she ain't
even thinking about that social media
phase if you're blowing
that that stuff if you're blowing her
away you know so she's just enamored
with you
and now she's not necessarily going back
and cleaning it out but she's not
necessarily looking backwards either
so what you have to do is you have to
say something like during the dating
phase like hey
yeah i don't keep photos of exes around
you know
i wouldn't get in a relationship of
somebody who kept photos or
especially couples photos of guys she
used to bang it's just not it sends the
wrong message
it lets to me it sends a message that
she still has a thing for that guy and
even if she doesn't
that guy thinks that that's the case and
i'm not going to be disrespected like
that and give
in a commitment so i'd never commit to
somebody who has that
i might say something like that or go i
might say well you notice that i don't
have pictures of
mike yeah it's a good way to put it so
it's a very good compliance test to have
her
to have her comply with your it's not a
demand but it's a request right
right and if she is going to resist that
but those are my memories that's one
thing you'll hear
really well if you want it and then i'll
just you can just say well
if i don't hold on to memories of chicks
i used to smash
and i'm not going to be in a commitment
with somebody that holds on to memories
who used to
of guys that used to smash them it's
just the way it is and then
and you just say it like matter of fact
like hey there's no relationship here if
you're holding on to this stuff
if she's unwilling to go backwards and
delete that stuff
then that's a problem now i mean you
know you never want to
she photos and like social media is
weird like i've had it happen before too
where like
because i do go backwards and i delete
like chicks i used to be with you know
what i mean because
once it's done it's done and that's how
i don't want to give her a message that
she has a chance you know and so i mean
that's
the way it is right and because they
always want to do that they always want
to circle back around my exes
always call and circle back around like
hey how's it going you're doing
right exactly and they want to they want
to know if they could
still get the d for me and if i'm with
somebody especially
that girls love that validation they
want me to do something or say something
that would make them think they have
something
on my ltr and i'm not going to give that
to them
you know what i mean no no way and so
that's why i remove that stuff but guess
what that's my value
that needs to be my chicks value too
right yeah so
for a different reason oh right um
remodel kc says using past photos is
social
proof which is which is one of the
reasons why they keep it up there right
another type of selfie yeah you can call
it whatever you want a selfie or a
portrait photo or it might even be
something
you know from an event um you know where
they're sitting down at the bar
or you know the table together but
either way the way that paul framed it i
think is a great way to go about it
and like women will compliance test men
they will always do it they you know
they do it to
basically ensure that you're the best
possible
uh guy that they can get you also need
to issue compliance tests to women and
as paul described there this is a good
example of one if she
you know she either complies with your
request or she doesn't and you have to
have a firm boundary around it
my view on it is if you ask her to
comply with something it's comply or
goodbye it's as simple as that let me
ask you this question because i've
because i've heard a couple of different
views on this i want to hear what your
view is on
um chick you know you suspect your texts
being
been alpha widowed maybe she's messaging
you know some dude from her past
or they've got some dialogue going uh
there
are you a fan of doing the phone check
what's your view on that for guys man
i'm not really a fan of
it but i mean
is there is there a way to go about
doing it where you don't come off as
a beta [ __ ] and you can still hold
frame
i struggle with this one because
i mean it's she's going to
so for example like my ltr my ltr
wouldn't even have a thought of me ever
going through her phone
because i'm her best and i know it and
so why would i ever do that why would i
care
plus she's very careful about her
boundaries with other guys
she does that because it's my standards
you know what i mean
and that's also her standards she sees
you know she might not have always had
those standards
but now that she's with me those are the
standards so her phone
is never like even password protected if
i wanted to go through her phone
i could go through her phone you know
what i mean she doesn't care she doesn't
try to protect it she doesn't try to
hide it
she doesn't try to hide texts hide
communications
she will mention or say things when
people contact her
you know okay so so let's rephrase it
let's say that you're in a relationship
with a check that you suspect has been
alpha widowed
right and there's possible
communications as alerts going off she's
got her phone face down when she's with
you
she runs off the phone in different
rooms and you want to verify something
here yeah is there a way that you can go
about that yeah come here
have a seat we got we got john in the
chat he says beta or not i
i check her phone i don't give af data
is data
all right so so here's how i've done
this before though in other situations
when
if you remember rich i really liked
toxic women i thought they were great
you know i don't know it's for my
stripper days when i was running
straight i don't know what it was
i was just like toxic women so i'd be in
these situations with these tacks of
women and these sort of relationships
and i would have to
like super alpha frame them and be
a real a-hole to them right and so in
that in situations where
where i've been tested like that i've
said come here have a seat put your
phone on the table
open it up let's go through it just like
just like that i'm not going to sneak
around i'm going to tell her to open
that
that phone right now if i have if i have
a thought or a question
we're doing it because you're and i tell
her it's i'm not
jealous and insecure but your behavior
is out of control
and you're acting like you're doing
something you shouldn't be doing and so
let's see what that is
and you know if you're discovered that
you're not her best that she's talking
to a guy from her past or maybe multiple
guys from her past
how would you handle that so let's say
she's having
you know conversations and flirting or
whatever
you know with a guy just i just look at
it and i'll say well
hope it was worth it close the phone and
that's it
relationship's over you know what i mean
and so and now
i'm walking away from it now maybe
there's a misunderstanding because this
is what i get from guys who
want consultations with me and stuff
they they're like well maybe what if i
misunderstood what if it really wasn't
like that
or what if she wasn't and so here's the
thing if that's
true what she's gonna do is
freak the hell out and try to get you
back with a level of fury that you've
never seen before
if you are mistaken and she's just
doing the wrong thing and being stupid
and so
having been with some toxic bpd type
women they do that
they they you're her best but they're
you know they have problems and
attachment problems and so forth and so
they do
certain things women [ __ ] alphas too by
the way
um when they cuck so just as something
to keep in mind women cook alpha is not
for the same reason though women cheat
on alphas not for the same reason
they do it for revenge and they do it
because they're worried or angry
or upset and they're but they're worried
about being discarded by him
so when a woman has like a toxic thing
and she's got extreme abandonment issues
like these bpd women
they'll keep guys around too and even
kind of let you find out about those
guys
to get to try to put a dread game on you
because they're you know they're they're
worried about being abandoned by you and
they're and they're even resentful or
mad at you for it it's not because they
don't see you as her best it's because
quite the contrary they see you as your
best and they're not convinced that they
can keep you
and they're mad at you for that and so
they you know i've seen these
scenarios where women will cheat with a
guy who's like a total beta tool bag
dork
on a guy who's like extreme almost too
aggressive alpha
but they're doing that because the guy
is such an a-hole and she's mad at him
and she doesn't think she can keep this
relationship together
and so it's a form of dread she even
lets that guy find out and it's a whole
thing right
so these are some advanced game here
tonight now paul this is a bit
advantageous
you